alors il ya des fois j'ai un petit peu
l'impression d'être le tonton boomer un
peu de film making sure you tube le gars
qui veut pas se mettre à la page et tous
les cons qui changent pas d'avis et je
suis quasiment sûr qu'après avoir vu
cette vidéo vous allez voir le format
vertical d'un autre oeil
et salue les gens derrière l'écran c'est
françois pour la chaîne explique mme
encore je suis ravi de vous retrouver
sur cette chaîne comme à chaque fois ici
on parle de comment faire de la vidéo de
montage de tournage d'astuces tout ça
tout ça donc si c'est quelque chose qui
vous intéresse vous pouvez envisager de
cliquer sur le petit bouton s'abonner
qui est situé juste en dessous alors le
format vertical c'est le truc à la mode
en ce moment entre tic toc les shorts de
youtube les rues ans d'instagram du
format vertical on en voit partout à
toutes les sauces et je me suis un petit
peu penché sur le sujet ce que je me
suis dit françois il ya sûrement des
choses à explorer là dessus c'est pas
parce que tu es habitué au format
horizontal que le format vertical c'est
forcément tous pourris je connaissais
déjà un petit peu les règles sur
instagram et je me suis inscrit il ya
quelques mois sur tik tok pour voir un
petit peu à quoi ça ressemblait je vais
vous raconter un petit peu mon parcours
sur la découverte de tik tok et je pense
que ça vous intéresse j'ai donc parcouru
un petit peu le site hélas hélas
émerveillement total j'ai découvert
quelque chose de fantastique de
qualitatif de merveilleux du génie en
soi non je déconne en fait c'est
vraiment de la grosse grosse daube
quasiment tous les trucs sur lequel je
suis tombé c'était creux à pleurer et
mal fait filmer au téléphone et est
vraiment pas intéressant pour moi dans
la grande majorité il y avait quelques
trucs un petit peu drôle ou des choses
qui étaient sympas et j'ai donc décidé
de désinstaller l'application voilà
désinstaller c'est fini merci au revoir
et l'histoire aurait pu s'arrêter là si
j'avais pas été un peu plus têtu je me
suis dit que la plateforme en elle même
était pas forcément mauvaise mais que
c'était plutôt le contenu qui ne me
convenait pas je dis que c'est mauvais
j'exagère un petit peu c'est juste pas à
mon goût et je comprends tout à fait
qu'ils aient des gens qui apprécient
regarder ce type de contenu là mais
c'est pas pour autant que j'allais y
poster du contenu tout pour y filmer à
l'iphone d'ailleurs je vous mets un lien
dans la description pour vous abonner à
mon compte tictoc si vous voulez puisque
vous pourrez voir comme ça ce que j
poste alors au début je ne savais pas
forcément trop quoi m ce n'est pas ce
qui convenait à la plate forme et
surtout je savais pas exploiter ce
format vertical du coup j'ai fait
quelques petites sd taloa pour montrer
et avant après je me suis dit tiens ça
peut être sympa ça peut intéresser les
gens il y en a un ou deux qui ont plutôt
bien fonctionné mais c'est en y
réfléchissant un peu plus notamment avec
mes potes bene guillaume les acteurs de
la websérie qu'on a tourné que je me
suis dit qu'il y avait peut-être un
enjeu en termes de cadrage en termes de
créativité qui permettrait d'exploiter
un petit peu ce format vertical c'est
pour ça qu'on a créé une autre chaîne
tik tok qui s'appelle balech je vous
mets aussi le lien en descriptions sur
laquelle on a mis des petites saynètes
humoristiques ou ans c'est beaucoup
beaucoup amusé à créer du contenu voilà
un petit peu plus scénarisées et surtout
pas filmé au téléphone filmé avec le z 6
il ya un mais certains qu'ils sont
filmés en pro à 0 juste pour le fun pour
pouvoir est talonné un petit peu
derrière
[Musique]
je relance
[Applaudissements]
tapie
et
puis le problème et rend que tik tok
compresse énormément les vidéos que
c'est énormément dégradée mais au final
une vidéo d'iphone dégradées et une
vidéo d'hybrides dégradé il en boit
quand même la différence c'est
d'ailleurs une de mes craintes un petit
peu quel va être le taux de dégradation
des vidéos au final on est assez
habitués sur tik tok à skis et cette
compression quel que soit le format
utilisé quel que soit le matériel
utilisé du coup une vidéo faite à
l'hybride ressort quand même beaucoup
mieux qu'une vidéo fait un niveau là je
me suis aussi posé la question est-ce
que je filme en 4k en horizontal comme
ici où est ce que je fais une rotation
sur mon pied pour filmer directement au
format vertical je me suis dit que pour
encore éviter le moins de compression
possible vais pas aller croquer dans mon
capteurs j'ai utilisé mon trépied en
mode vertical g incliné la caméra pour
avoir vraiment la pleine résolution de
ce que j'allais faire et de ce que
j'allais poster et c'est là je me suis
dit que c'était très intéressant et que
ça m'a mis un petit peu le cerveau en
ébullition c'est à dire que je suis
tellement habituée à filmer à
l'horizontale que cette rotation m'a
complètement de perturber dans ma façon
de filmer et c'était très très bien
justement de sortir de ma zone de
confort me dire voilà j'ai pas la
largeur que j'ai d'habitude pourtant je
dois composer un cadre qui soit
esthétique qui soit jolie et qui ait du
sens et je vous encourage à aller voir
un petit peu les différentes formes à
que j'ai fait sur les différentes
chaînes tik tok ça va encore évoluer
j'ai encore beaucoup de choses à
apprendre sur ce format là mais je pense
que ça mérite d'être tenté c'est un
petit peu comme la photo en mode
portrait ou en mode paysage on
photographie pas de la même façon
pourtant les deux existent et je vois
pas pourquoi pour la vidéo ça
n'existerait pas non plus même si on est
très habitué à ce format large à ce
format cinémascope aussi que j'aime
énormément je trouve que filmer en
vertical ça nous met face à une
contrainte qui vous rend plus créatif
alors ne monte pas au créneau ne vous
inquiétez pas je vais pas me mettre à
faire que du tic toc et à faire que du
vertical j'aime trop le format paysage
pour arrêter et puis dans les projets de
fictions de clips et tout ça je suis pas
sûr que ce soit le média le plus
pertinent surtout que quand on filme en
4k il ya tout à fait moyen de croo paix
dans l'image pourra préfère des release
faire des tic toc faire des shorts non
pas les choses les choses c'est vraiment
vraiment vraiment de la daube la youtube
vous avez merdé je suis vraiment pas sûr
que ce soit là qui est fine mettre son
format vertical un clairement et puis au
delà de l'aspect créatif ya aussi
l'aspect visibilité je vous cache pas
que j'ai une entreprise à faire tourner
j'ai des réseaux sociaux à faire tourner
et clairement les algorithmes de tik tok
où des rixes d'instagram mettent
énormément en avant ses formes à la il
ya beaucoup plus de chances de toucher
de nouvelles personnes avec ces formats
verticaux qu'avec une vidéo youtube par
exemple parce qu'on va pas se mentir non
plus youtube c'est quand même assez
sclérosé c'est difficile d'aller
chercher de nouvelles personnes c'est
difficile de montrer son travail à de
nouvelles personnes et clairement tik
tok où les risques sur instagram c'est
un moyen de faire découvrir son travail
et pour moi c'est aussi très important
de pouvoir développer un petit peu cette
visibilité là mais pas à n'importe quel
prix j'ai discuté avec un abonné qui a
percé sur tik tok et qui a quatre cent
mille abonnés maintenant sur sa chaîne
tik tok qui me disait tu devrais pas te
prendre la tête à faire de belles vidéos
sur tik tok à utiliser ton réflexe tu
devrais le faire plus tôt au téléphone
ça marche beaucoup mieux et le réflexe
c'est presque même contre-productif et
ça même si la raison complètement et je
pense que c'est clairement ce qu'il
faudrait faire c'est parce que j'ai
envie de faire format vertical certes
format court tik tok certes aussi mais
je veux que ça reste beau parce que mon
métier c'est vidéaste mon métier c'est
de faire de belles images j'ai pas envie
de faire des vidéos avec mon téléphone
même si on peut faire de très très
belles vidéos avec le téléphone c'est
pas ma spécialité moi mes vidéos elles
sont jolies quand je les filme avec une
caméra ou un hybride alors on pourrait
se dire du coup bas contenu de qualité
sur le format court 30 secondes 45
secondes c'est super ça va percer machin
tout ça il ya quand même un problème ce
problème il est de taille c'est que à
mon avis pour l'instant sur tik tok il
n'y a pas la demande de montres contenu
c'est à dire des choses pour expliquer
comment faire de belles vidéos puisque
par définition les gens les fonds aux
smartphones mais je me rappelle de
youtube à ses débuts quand on avait des
nordmann et des sites rien qui se filmer
avec des caméras gopro voire même de la
webcam et c'était tout pourri cdpa
professionnaliser finalement ça a quand
même beaucoup évolué et aujourd'hui sur
youtube c'est compliqué de sortir du lot
si tu filmes pas avec 1 min homme de
qualité et je fais le pari que tik tok à
un moment donné ça va tenir comme ça
c'est un réseau social qui est quand
même jeunes même si ça fait deux trois
ans que ça existe c'est en train
d'exploser maintenant mais il n'y a pas
vraiment de modèle économique pour les
créateurs dessus y'a pas vraiment encore
de choses très installé et à un moment
il va falloir se démarquer je pense que
aujourd'hui faire du contenu de qualité
sur tik tok c'est un investissement sur
l'avenir parce que plus tard et je peux
me tromper mais je pense que les
contenus vont évoluer en terme de
qualité et que le fait d'être présent
sur la plateforme avec du contenu de
qualité dès le départ ça peut être un
élément différenciant donc pourquoi pas
ne pas essayer l'avantagent de ses
créations sur tik tok c'est que ça prend
assez peu de temps par exemple hier j'ai
tourné cinq vidéos tik tok ça m'a pris
une heure le montage m'a pris une petite
heure de plus et je sais que je vais
pouvoir dispatcher ces vidéos dans le
temps c'est pas très chronophage au
final ça ne coûte pas grand chose de le
faire si ça marche tant mieux et si ça
marche pas c'est pas grave du tout dans
tous les cas je me suis amusé et donc au
final c'est pas tant elles sont pas
pourris c'est le contenu qu'on va mettre
dessus qui va faire en sorte que ce soit
cool ou pas donc à nous de les rendre
cool et de remonter un petit peu de
niveaux en mettant un coup de blaster
sur le pouce en l'air qui situe juste en
dessous de cette vidéo en s'abonnant à
cette chaîne et pour poursuivre un petit
peu ça je vous encourage à aller voir la
vidéo qui s'affiche ici et qui vous
donne des conseils pour améliorer encore
plus aux vidéos ciao